[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
uh
welcome back everyone it's charlie this
is going to be my new mandalorian season
2 boba fett video there was a big
mandalorian season 2 panel over the last
weekend where john favreau and a lot of
the filmmakers were talking about the
season 2 episodes the new season 2
characters
specifically boba fett baby yoda the
mandalorian character so we'll break it
all down
there's also some casting news about
other really big characters that they're
bringing to live action from some of the
animated series like grand admiral
thrawn so i'll address that during the
video too but this is mostly going to be
about boba fett and the mandalorian
season 2.
if you're new to the channel be sure to
subscribe to get all the videos we'll do
a new amazon giveaway
all you have to do to enter is be a
subscriber and let me know which other
characters from the original trilogy or
the tv shows you want them to bring to
the live action series
so just going down the list starting
with number five all this mandalorian
season two panel stuff is from the atx
television festival they did a special
pre-recorded panel because they're still
working on the mandalorian season 2 in
post-production right now
they talked about a bunch of stuff
during season 2 in the series in general
and the character arcs
but some of the most important stuff was
clarifying why they chose to do the boba
fett character especially after jon
favreau implied last year that they
weren't gonna do
him before season one premiered what
they chose to change about the character
given the star wars timeline from the
movies and the other canon tv shows like
the clone wars and confirmed some of my
theories about what's going on with this
character during season two
the overall themes of redemption
inherent to the series itself
also through the dinjarin mandalorian
character in baby yoda so remember that
idea too
redemption all about redemption boba
fett's story during season two
and season three will make a little more
sense too when you hear john favreau's
quote here
this is one of his more important bow
effect quotes he said we all love boba
fett but we never got as much of him as
we all
wanted he's talking about in the
original trilogy he came to an
unceremonious end in return of the jedi
we wanted somebody that could kind of
live up to what we had hoped to see
when we were younger so number four what
that means for boba fett in season two
is that they intend to quote redeem the
character after the hilarious way he
went out in return of the jedi falling
into the sarlacc pit
he was such a badass during empire
strikes back he was hyped up
so much and they just went out so
hilariously
during return of the jedi the most
badass bounty hunter in the galaxy just
falls right into the pit because he gets
knocked in the back
a lot of the inspiration for the
mandalorian series in general when they
were developing it came from the boba
fett character as well as because we
have dave filoni from the clone wars
mandalorian storylines
but all that stuff during the clone wars
spun out of the backstory that started
in the original trilogy with that boba
fett character so it all goes back to
boba fett
so because the boba fett character is so
important to the mandalorian series
metaphorically
and practically that's why they wanted
to bring him on also because they wanted
to do justice to the character
the only other big boba fett stories
that we've had within the star wars
universe that are still canon right now
are actually during the clone wars
daniel logan who played the young boba
fett during attack of the clones
came back to play a slightly older
version of the character during the
clone wars animated series
and it just pushed him slowly along the
path of becoming the boba fett of
present day
he's jango's son
yes yes sorry about your father
he was a friend and an honorable man
but it's temura morrison that's playing
the older boba fett that we'll see
during the mandalorian season two
because
if you want to be accurate about it boba
fett was a clone of jango fett
temura morrison played jango fett he
played all the clones so he would also
play boba fett in present day too
but because they now confirmed the
teaser from the mandalorian episode 5
post credit scene or that end tag scene
where he's walking up
inspecting mina's body it just confirms
that they're doing a version of the
aftermath story which is
canon to star wars right now i know
there's always a lot of questions about
what's canon what's not canon i'll get
into that in a second too but for the
most part
the aftermath novel just deals with the
aftermath of return of the jedi what
happens after that to the empire
and what happens on tatooine after the
sarlacc pit here
the reason why you don't see boba fett
wearing his classic armor in the
mandalorian episode 5 here which is
taking place five years after return of
the jedi is explained during the
aftermath novel
because what happens is is you find a
character named cobb vance who i think
is being played by timothy oliphant
during the mandalorian season 2
is seen arguing with jawas over a set of
mandalorian armor which just happens to
be
boba fett's classic armor which
apparently the jaw was found around the
sarlacc pit
they had a couple funny moments with the
jawas during mandalorian season one just
to remind you that they do stuff like
that they'll take
anything that they can find like they
were trying to steal moff gideon's tie
fighter rip it apart with him still
incited
so number three there was that report
from the set that timothy oliphant was
seen
wearing a version of the boba fett
mandalorian armor in his scenes
so if you didn't see my last season 2
video he is playing a character during
at least one episode for season 2. we
don't know which episode
it's going to be but as most people have
guessed even if you haven't read the
aftermath novel you may have seen people
talking about it
if he's playing the cobb vance character
who gets boba fett's armor from the
jawas who scavenged it from the sarlacc
pit
it would explain who he's playing but
the aftermath novel doesn't tell you
exactly what happens to boba fett
himself so the mandalorian season 2
is writing all that new boba fett's
story into the canon themselves
and if the series is all about
redemption as john favreau says the
redemption of denjarin's character
through baby yoda
in john favreau references that when
talking about boba fett
they also probably intend to give boba
fett a similar redemption arc
during season two and if rumors are to
be believed season three
right now the reports are that temura
morrison's boba fett character isn't
going to be featured a lot during season
2 but he'll have more episodes during
season 3.
but just because they're giving boba
fett a redemption arc during the
mandalorian series doesn't mean they're
suddenly going to make his alignment
lawful good
they're still all about staying true to
the characters and he's a true neutral
character as a bounty hunter so he's
capable of helping the mandalorian just
as much as he'd sell him out to moff
gideon for a fat
bounty paycheck on baby yoda but if you
got worried when you heard that boba
fett would show up during season
two that he'd be some sort of gimmick or
a one-and-done cameo
we'd never see him again or they kill
him off like a punk all of john
favreau's comments
imply that that is not the case and even
though they are developing a bunch of
mandalorian series spin-offs i don't
think that they have plans to do a boba
fett spin-off he could always show up
during the live-action ahsoka series
that they've been talking about doing
the obi-wan kenobi series said in the
past or others
but outside of future mandalorian
seasons i think that's it
and he would just always be played by
temuera morrison when he does show up
number two also during this big panel
jon favreau confirmed the baby yoda's
character arc is meant to reflect the
mandalorians personal history and how
that affected their relationship arc
baby yoda being a foundling just like
the mandalorian was the mando and the
armor both call him a foundling on
separate occasions
and now he takes it into his care as a
father figure just like the death watch
mandalorians took him in when they saved
him during the clone wars
because of these themes i do like the
theory that the title of the series the
mandalorian
is also a reference to baby yoda like
he's the mandalorian
because they make a big deal about
dinjara not being born a mandalorian he
became one through training taking their
oath upholding their code of honor
following their customs
so one day baby yoda could also do the
same thing in a sense
as cute as it is seeing all this fan art
of him walking around with a mandalorian
helmet designed for
giant yoda's species ears i don't think
we'd ever see an older version of him
walking around
in a giant mandalorian helmet but
metaphorically he becomes a mandalorian
through his inclusion in mando's tribe
of two as the armor tells him
but number one some of you were asking
me about the grand admiral thrawn
casting news
so apparently it's been reported the
grand admiral thrawn is going to come
into the live-action series at some
point
the news reports didn't specify if the
character would be appearing on the
mandalorian or if he was supposed to
appear on the ahsoka series or some
other series
but the character is still alive in
present day until proven otherwise
so here's where we get into what's canon
and what's not canon for grand admiral
thrawn if you read the thrawn novels
most of those are great but they're not
canon anymore there is a new canon
thrawn novel but it's set way further in
the past
before star wars rebels the last time we
officially saw thrawn in its
canon was at the end of star wars rebels
he was last seen being jumped into
hyperspace into the unknown regions via
a giant hyperspace whale and that's it
you just have to wonder what happened to
him and ezra bridger
there were also some rumors that they
were planning on doing a live-action
ezra bridger on the disney plus series
at some point too
that could also be for the ahsoka series
so until we hear
otherwise just most people are assuming
that if there is thrawn in live action
it will be for some other series it
won't be for the mandalorian
right now moff gideon is still meant to
be the big bad for the mandalorian
series
and the other good news too is that jon
favreau reiterated that the mandalorian
season 2 episodes would start being
released in october this year just like
they originally planned
no big delays because the virus or
anything like that
he didn't give the exact date but right
now marvel is currently still releasing
one division episodes in december
so in order for that schedule to work
they'd have to start dropping
mandalorian season two episodes by
october 9th in order to get them all
out before one division starts so until
we get an official release date just
pencil that in
vaguely sometime mid-october
congratulations to the giveaway winner
from my last big star wars video anarchy
please email me on the about page of my
channel so i can get your contact
details
everyone click here for all my
mandalorian season 2 videos
and click here for my brand new batman
movie video
thank you so much for watching everyone
stay safe i'll see you guys tonight
[Music]
you